is there negative aspects to money like
for example it becoming harder to find
people you can trust
I think the most negative aspect is that
it amplifies
a 360 degree view of your personality
because there are a lot of people and
Society tells you that more money is
actually better you are a better person
somehow and you're factually more
worthwhile than some other people that
have less money
that's also a lie but when you're given
that kind of attention it's very easy
for you to become a caricature of
yourself
um that's probably the single worst
thing that happens to you but I say it
in the opposite way I think all I've
ever seen in Silicon Valley as an
example
um is that when somebody gets a hold of
a lot of money it tends to cause them to
become exactly who they were meant to be
they're either a kind person they're
either a curious person they're either a
jerk you know they're either cheap and
they can use all kinds of masks but now
that there's no expectations and Society
gives you a get out of jail free card
you start to behave the way that's most
comfortable to you so you see somebody's
innate personality
and that's a really interesting thing to
observe because then you can very
quickly bucket sort where do you want to
spend time and who is really you know
additive to your gameplay
and who is really a negative detractor
to your gameplay you're an investor but
you're also kind of philosopher
um you analyze the world in all these
different uh perspectives on all in
podcasts on Twitter everywhere uh
do you worry that money makes puts you
out of touch
from
being able to truly empathize with the
experience of the general population
which in part first of all on a human
level that could be limiting but also as
an analyst of human civilization that
could be limiting
I think it definitely can for a lot of
people because it's just a it's an
abstraction for you to stop caring right
um I also think the other thing is that
you can very quickly especially in
today's world become the scapegoat just
to use the gerardian like Renee Gerard
if you look if you think about like
memetic theory in a nutshell
you know we're all competing
for these very scarce resources that we
are told is worthwhile and if you view
the world through that gerardian lens
what are we really doing we're all
fighting for scarce resources whether
that's Twitter followers money Acclaim
notoriety and we all compete with each
other and in that competition
you know Gerard writes like the only way
you escape that Loop is by scapegoating
something or somebody
and I think we are in that Loop right
now where just the fact of being
successful is a thing that one should
scapegoat to end all of this you know
tension that we have in the world
I I think that it's a little misguided
because I don't think it solves the
fundamental problem
um and we can talk about the solution to
some of these problems are but
um that's I think the loop that we're
all living and so if you become a
character caricature and you feed
yourself into it
I mean you're not doing anything to to
Really Advance things